Okay, it's Mark wiens here making Thai street food recipes today
We're going to do a recipe for Lab Mu which is a minced pork
Thai salad um and it's an awesome dish
you
Alright, so the base of this dish is minced pork
But you could also use minced chicken or minced beef you'll also need tae sticky rice some dried chili flakes a little bit of sugar
Fish sauce lime juice some shallots Culantro. Which is sort of like cilantro?
Green onions and mint leaves
Also, you can click below this video in the description box to see all of the ingredients and the directions for this recipe an important
ingredient in Lab mole is
Kokua and what that is this is Connie, Al which is sticky Rice Thai sticky rice. Do you have to roast it?
So you have to basically just cook it over a fire
in a hot frying pan and then after that Gonna kind of pounded up
So that's going to give the pork sell at some like a little crunch some texture to it. So the first step. We're gonna
Roast the sticky rice first step you want to turn on the fire to a low heat add
The sticky rice to the pan and then kind of continually stir it so the heat get sort of evenly
Distributed on the rice in about 15 minutes the sticky rice is turning really yellow almost looks like sweet and actually smells like popcorn
for pounding
It's best to have a stone mortar and pestle and then you just keep pounding the the rice until you have a coarse powder
Took me about five minutes or so
And once you're done with that you can scoop it out of the crop and then put it into a bowl aside
You'll come back to it later
Okay, so turn on the stove again this time. We want a really high heat and we'll be using a small sauce pan pot
I'd say fry it for about five minutes
And you want the pork to be completely gray and completely cooked through
When it's done fully cooked through you just take it off the heat
And you're actually done with the stove for this recipe on [the] streets of thailand
They mix the lab right in the same pot
So just grab your toasted rice add probably a big heaping tablespoon full add
Half to one tablespoon of dried chili flakes
I'll depending on how spicy you want it tiny Sprinkle of sugar and
About half a tablespoon of fish sauce next step is to slice up one good-sized lime and squeeze it into the pot
I like [my] pretty sour so if you want it less sour you might start with just half a lime and taste test from there
Give the lab a quick stir to get those dry ingredients all mixed into the pork
And then it's time to get started peeling the shallots
So you want to peel the skin off the shallots then dice them into half rings?
Before tossing them all into the pot you can grab the green onions and the culantro if you have it you want to just chop
off the roots first and then you can slice the
Green onions really fine these herbs are going to give the cell at a wonderful fresh and just a green
Touch that just gives it awesome flavor
give it a quick stir right now to get those all mixed in and then you want to pluck some leaves of mint and
Just sort of put them into the into the pork
This time you just want to give the lob a slight stir
So you don't like really crush those mint leaves um just up just a little mix oh
Oh, yeah
It's Salty I
Think we could use a little bit of lime juice actually I like my [feel] pretty sour a little more lime juice
And that should be just about perfecto
Going to Garnish it with some
leaves of mint
some sprigs of Culantro, and then finally some
Thai basil Thai sweet basil on the side and that is looking
Outstanding check this out. This is
my version of a ThAi street food Dish Larb Moo
Hmm. Oh
That's just a like a refreshing me d. Porky salad so many awesome flavors
Got that good lime juice a little bit of crunch from the from the roasted rice
and
Then you've got those herbs to to give it that nice herbaceous tinge to it
That's really good